Though when we zoom in and look at graphs, we're really only seeing part of the
entire representation of the function. We're just zooming in on this little
tiny portion of the domain. If we zoom out even just a bit though, we can see
that all these changes that are happening in the middle of the graph. Are
really just tiny details the overall behavior of the function is determined by
what's happening at either end of the graph on the right side and on the left
side. We've already learned a lot about the general shape of polynomial
functions so let's see if you can apply what you've learned. To work out how
each of these graphs will look. For each function I've listed here please tell
me what the behavior on the left side of the graph is going to look like. In
other words, what direction the graph is coming from? And then also tell me
what's happening on the right side of the graph. What direction is the graph
pointing in as we move over to the right hand side?